always tab on tv
tab on e-t tab writing books
and you getting hooked
that gets a standing ovation truly a
standing ovation
welcome to very good mondays i am your
host tabitha brown
i can do that if i want to because it's
my business my life is changing
right before my eyes good god this thing
is good
i kind of just want to start by you
telling me a little bit about
who you are your life um where you're
from and what the early
phases of tabitha brown looked like i'm
from a little town called eden north
carolina it's a small city
little you know country girl honey at
heart
and i have always always wanted to
perform ever since i was a little girl
we used to watch the cosby show when i
was a kid and i just tell my mom i want
to be rudy's friend that ring the
doorbell next and come inside and play
and then come home
i didn't know i was trying to say i want
to be an actor right i got into theater
really early in school i
love like music class i love to dance i
love to you know
sing and have fun and do theater and
then in high school i was very much so
and still am a hippie
and so i had um used to make my own
clothes i would thrift all the time and
then redesign
stuff and it was just a thing that i
enjoyed
and someone was telling me to go to
college i remember my mom said i know
that you want to you know be an actor
but it's so
hard but you also are really good at you
know making clothes
why don't you study fashion design so
you have something to fall back on
and i ended up going to school in miami
uh international fine
arts college uh to study fashion design
and i was there for a couple months and
i remember thinking like
i don't know i still think i should be
acting right
you still have the bug yeah i had that
bug inside of me and i woke up in the
middle of the night a wednesday night i
remember like yesterday was like one in
the morning and i called my dad and i
said daddy you need to come get me on
wasting your money
i said i'm supposed to be an actress i
can't i can't do this right now my daddy
did not hesitate he said well you know
what
i get off work at the meal on friday i
get on the road and i'll be there by
saturday morning pick you up because
it's a 14-hour drive
i have shelves yeah good man
oh i love i have the best dad in the
world and my mom had had a friend that
you know had a friend rather who lived
in california who had told me like maybe
a couple years ago if you ever want to
move to california you could always come
and
you know rent a room for me and so
that's what i decided to do within a
week's time i said i'm just going to go
to california and i'm just going to make
it right
no plan no plan girl no plan i'm just
going out here
to hollywood and i'm going to make it
i'm 19 years old and
free okay how much money in your pocket
listen i probably had twelve hundred
dollars i get to california the one
thing the lady didn't tell me was aydah
she was crazy
she was taking all my money right she
wasn't really trying to
help me and i wasn't in hollywood where
i was down in the south of orange county
in laguna niguel it was beautiful
but i was nowhere near hollywood right
far from the auditions yes
so far and and now i'm working two jobs
just to afford to pay
her and i didn't want to tell my family
and
my husband was my boyfriend at the time
and i didn't want to tell him how bad it
was because we had a plan that i'll be
out here for a couple months then you
come out and then we'll get our own
place right
in la so i didn't want to tell him that
you know this i'm not even able to save
any money
she's pretty much taking everything i
got and so when he moved
out a couple months later he was like
this is insane
hey you're not doing any acting you're
working two jobs he said we should move
back to north carolina
save up for one year then move to los
angeles so you can really pursue your
dream
and so we ended up moving back to
greensboro north carolina because we
didn't want to go back home
so we chose the biggest city closest to
home
and that was greensboro and then the
one-year plan
turned into five years of baby
marriage you know house cars jobs and
all these new responsibilities
and most important a forgotten dream i
really
tried to forget about it i just
convinced myself that you know what i
missed out on my opportunity
i i have a baby now i got all these new
responsibilities i'm just gonna have to
settle for
working a regular job and you know being
you know a traditional
person not that anything is wrong with
that but i just
became content and got on my knees and i
started to pray and i said god if this
is you
speaking to me i need you to show me a
sign today because if not i'm gonna go
ahead and turn myself into the crazy
house
and so later that day we were on our way
to the mall and on the radio station a
dj named buster brown came on and said
hey guys i just got a new tv show on the
wb network
and i'm holding auditions looking for a
female co-host
i was like oh my god this is my sign
this is what i
asked the lord to show me right and so i
ended up going to that audition and it
was tons of girls there
but i ended up booking that job i would
drive three hours to wilmington north
carolina just to do
extra work so i would know what it felt
like to be on a real tv set
and that show was one tree hill and i
was just thinking okay and i did that
for about a year
and i told my husband now it's time for
us to move to los angeles we saved eight
thousand dollars
and in 2004 uh except the end of
october we drove and moved to los
angeles
and then no sooner than we got here just
a couple months later my mom got sick
back in north carolina
and she was diagnosed with als and my
whole world stopped and i thought
you only get one mom and so i went back
home
for the next three years often on to
help care for my mother and be with her
until she passed away
and so after my mom passed away i
thought you know what
i'm gonna go for it i gotta i gotta do
whatever i can do to make this thing
happen
and this was 2007 and i just came right
back
into la and just jumped in to do it
that's when blockbuster was saying i did
a bunch of back-to-back like
little indie feature films they went
straight to blockbuster that i hope died
with blockbuster but
whatever no things that you were in back
in the day are now like
treasured artifacts and you know your
fans are probably looking on youtube
trying to find everything
i want to kind of fast forward a little
bit um to 2017
a sandwich changes your life you make a
video about it if you got a whole foods
value go today deli
ask for this ttla add a pickle
and watch your life change honey
i'm looking around and stuff look
different that's how good it is
i mean what do you make of that you know
what's so crazy
i had never wanted to do videos anyway
right i never want to do anything with
food
why i had this dream when i was because
i was sick i was sick for a year and a
half
and i wasn't able to audition anymore i
wasn't able to really you know do my
acting i was depressed i had anxiety
and i thought okay god revealed that to
me what is that and
in my prayer i heard him say start doing
videos and i didn't want to do it but i
had
also made a promise to god if he had
healed me that i would do whatever he
asked
and so i would you know start doing
these videos and nobody was watching
just a couple hundred views i would get
and so but i was consistent i had been
on disability for over a year so i was
broke
my savings was gone and i started
driving uber october of 2017
and then december 30th of 2017 i dropped
somebody off by
a whole foods that morning and i thought
oh whole foods always got a good vegan
option i'm still a new vegan a couple
months in
i'm going to get some breakfast and it
was a sandwich called a tlta
it was like a bot but with vegan bacon
and so i did a video to tell people i
found this new sandwich
i posted it on facebook went back to
driving uber i think nothing of it i get
home and you know go to my facebook and
turn my notifications on my phone was
buzzing like a
amber alert or something girl like what
in the world the video had over 50 000
views and i was like
who is watching this video and the next
morning had over a hundred thousand
views and i told my husband i think i'm
going bible
he was like what does that mean i was
like i don't know he was like why are
you gonna make any money i was like i
don't know
i hope so yeah right and then within
four days whole foods reached out and
said oh my god we saw your video we'd
love to work with you
well how about we make some french toast
with raisin bread
our way didn't make us feel like maybe
we're in friends
or just in another room in the house
i think i did my first cooking video on
march 8th or
march 9th and it took off pretty quick
and our first month i had a million
followers
a week after i had 2 million and then
the next month i had 3 million and today
is 4 months i've been on tick tock and i
got 4 million followers
it is crazy honey every day i wake up
embrace it baby you are simply beautiful
all of you the day that i saw ellen's
digital network
announcing tabitha brown is getting her
own talk show
i screamed a little bit with excitement
because i think you're just you're born
to do it
um what do you know about it are you
already having development meetings is
there a title tell me everything
the show is called all love with tabitha
brown and i'm doing
uh everything you know motherhood
parenting and
food family fun conversation you know
highlights of the week just different
things that are all
a positive energy and just a good time
excited to you know start that right
here in my home
uh starting in august and then hopefully
it'll be out
in september have you had a chance to uh
zoom with ellen have you guys had
personal conversations
no not yet and ellen called me girl but
no not yet you know crazy enough
i worked on the ellen show it was a
sketch comedy for uh a little sketch for
amazon for the amazon alexa
and so i had worked with her team before
and amazing people
loved them so i'm so excited that it
came back around
in the way that it did look how you
manifested that like to the 10th degree
right is there a dream guest i mean are
you are you
contacting celebrities or influencers
people that you're just like i gotta get
you on my show
i would love to to do something with
michelle obama i love perry michelle
girl where you at girl
i feel like you guys are the truly the
two queens of my universe actually
at oprah there's the trifecta right
there i love oprah as well i love oprah
uh it's it's amazing to me and like even
you know to be even in the space and can
fathom it all right and that it's coming
to fruition honey anybody that i
am blessed to be in the presence of it's
just such a gift
kind of with that i do know that at your
core
you're an actress you're an entertainer
and i'm hoping that you'll share the
story
of how you went from working at the
century city mall
to being represented by the massive
agency that's across the street how did
you make that happen
oh wow it's crazy you know when i first
came to la i worked at macy's in central
city for years
and uh i would go on my lunch break
sometime and you know
walk the block and i would always see
caa and say oh god one day lord
i just kind of point to it with my hands
like one day i'm gonna be there
and uh after being on tick-tock and
getting even more exposure they reached
out and so i would always say that one
day they'll come looking for me
i ain't gonna have to go looking for
them they're gonna find me i would
always say that
and i guess i spoke it into existence
you know being with caa
and them being behind you believing in
you seeing your talent
i'm sure the opportunities the
floodgates i'm sure have been opened but
i want to know a little bit about your
experience
as an actress trying to make it did you
experience the rejection did you
experience racism did you experience
discrimination oh my god honey
absolutely
all of that right um i've been pursuing
acting for 22 years
and so many different things came about
you know there was a time where i wasn't
free because i was told for so long no
you can't wear your natural hair you
need to wear it straight
cover your accent because nobody wants
to hear you know a southern accent
sometimes
especially with black people it's it
sounds ignorant
i've heard agents tell me that right
um you know trying to be a certain size
literally starving myself for years to
try to always be a certain look
uh that's not being free that's me
trying to fit into what i think
hollywood wants
and i wasn't free but honey i'm free now
but so many no's rejection after
rejection after rejection
uh sometimes you know the
the crazy thing is you would see you go
into an audition right
and then you'll see the project and the
person looks absolutely nothing like you
or they're not even black
and it's like why did you even call me
[Laughter]
what kept you going the thing that lives
inside
right the voice that i hear i know
there's a plan on my life
and that has always kept me going i know
that something is coming
i don't know what it is i know something
is coming despite everything that i've
been through
you've been patient you've put in the
hard work everyone is recognizing you
for the talented
incredible woman that you are is there a
project
in development is there something
brewing that you can share with us
well it it is kind of exclusive i mean i
i've
told people that you know i've always
want to be america's mom right yes
and i have always said if i had a tv
show it would be um claire huxtable
meets roseanne right in the middle
that would be my show right and so i'm
actually in development for that show
right now um and i signed on with max
mutchnick who's the creator of will and
grace he's my show runner
and so nobody really knows that yet
you were on will and grace so this is
another
full circle moment hey joe we can wrap
it up here
god bless you yeah see there's no crime
here
this one took a brutal dump in the
jungle
the rest of this damage is just part of
her cover-up it's a sitcom
it's based on my life of course
exaggerated but as a wife and as a
mother but
a woman who's trying to balance her
family while not losing herself in the
process so you know
that got to be a comedy girl because if
not we all be crying every week okay
it's very good mondays and
i started off with my glasses because
that's my business i would love to ask
about your family
what does your husband and your kids
what do they think of this
super stardom that has changed your life
you know what they're so supportive they
you know
we're in quarantine so it doesn't really
feel that different
right it feels like it just feels like
i'm working more on my computer i'm
doing more
videos but because we're in quarantine
they don't we don't feel it yet it's
like i'm still a mom
i'm so white right and they are my
foundation
right so they will always be come before
any of this stuff
but they love it they're excited for me
i'm excited for them because i always
try to include my family from the very
beginning
it was important to me if i'm gonna go
on this journey
uh that my family comes with me because
i we're not sold separately
okay of course people have fallen in
love with your entire family
and we're all just waiting for the day
that you'll hopefully say yes to a
reality show
is that a conversation you're having yes
absolutely that's another exclusive
we're
in pitch meetings right now for networks
so we'll see where we land
there anything off limits because you
know reality tv can get dicey and they
want to talk about this they want to
talk about that
what limits or boundaries are you going
to set there you know what there will be
no drama nothing
crazy i want to show the world a
positive
strong black family it is important in
our community right
and it's important for everybody right
now to see black people
as we are who we are right and be
relatable
to everyone in the world and that is my
mission with sharing my family
you're a unit and i think that's what
makes you a really powerful
group and you know i i would be remiss
to not ask you this we're in the middle
of a civil rights movement right now and
i know you and your husband are super
transparent and very open with your kids
but
i am curious what kinds of conversations
you have with your children
about being black in america and about
how you combat racism
oh absolutely the unfortunate thing is
that even though he's 80
we've already had to start having
uncomfortable conversations with
him and we just tell them unfortunately
there is
people in the world they're good people
and they're bad people
and unfortunately because you are a
little black boy with
beautiful brown skin some people just
may not like you
and that's not your problem that's their
problem
right and i always tell them every day
you are amazing
you are enough and don't ever let the
world tell you anything different
and he's powerful he is uh supposed to
be here
he belongs in this world he's worthy of
everything that god gives him
and uh you know he's special no matter
what
and the same with my daughter she's 18
now about to be 19 but she went through
a really rough time
with us here living in in the valley in
california getting bullied because of
her skin being dark and
she was one of the only black kids in
her class so it took a toll on her for a
very long time so i'm so
thankful now that uh she has become so
confident and embracing
her beauty as it is it's a hard task
but not too hard right we have to do it
we have to educate our kids we have to
empower them
let them know they're enough every
single day